[Musique]
françois hollande a prononcé son dernier
discours officiel lors de la cérémonie
de commémoration de l'esclavagé dans les
jardins du luxembourg au sénat un
président vous allez l'entendre soucieux
d'assurer la transmission on écoute
c'est une communion philosophique alors
que notion partagée
c'est aussi une transmission et avait
pour lui sûrement l'émotion liée à sa
première sortie comme présidente élue au
delà du 18 mai et puis il ya la proche
de la transmission effective qui viendra
le 14 faty vedra planches et qui
scellera à ce moment-là ça sa prise de
fonction j'en ai terminé avec cérémonie
comme président de la république
mais la politique elle est celle que
tout citoyen quelle a été sa place quel
était son rôle
quelle que soit sa position doivent
avoir à l'esprit la police et l'ati de
la france la police et les choix
essentiels pour le pays
et donc nul ne peut se mettre à l'écart
et il ya toujours l'utilité
se poser cette même question qui revient
sans cesse comment puis je être utile à
mon pays c'est à cette question que je
vais répondre maintenant réfléchir en
travaillant en produisant et en
intervenant cas ça me paraît tranquille
il s'agissait de la 12e journée
nationale des mémoires de la traite de
l'esclavagé et de leurs abolitions
une cérémonie en présence on vient de le
voir de françois hollande mais aussi d'
emmanuel macron sur le thème de la
transmission des mémoires pantin calmer
c'est la deuxième fois que les deux
présidents se retrouvent ensemble à
quelques jours de la passation de
pouvoir est à l'occasion de la 12e
cérémonie de commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
une cérémonie comme à l'accoutumée
organisée dans les jardins du sénat
et je le reste voilà oui monsieur mais
il est entraîneur on ne peut pas
j'organise
emmanuel macron plus effacé que lundi
sous l'arc de triomphe
car aujourd'hui il s'agit de la dernière
cérémonie officielle du quinquennat de
françois hollande
et pour cet ultime discours le président
a insisté sur sa politique mémorielle
il s'agit pas d'opposer une douleur à
une autre la concurrence des mémoires
est un mensonge
il n'y a pas de reine de hiérarchie dans
l'horreur de la souffrance dans la
barbarie
nous ne sommes pas là pour faire des
comparaisons nous sommes là pour
empêcher que ce qui a été le pire puisse
se reproduire
l'occasion également d'inviter son
successeur à reprendre le flambeau et
nous devons continuer à nous battre
contre les divisions qui déchirent les
peuples y compris ici contre les
discours qui jette les gens les uns
contre les autres
contre les as les intégristes contre les
obscurantistes contre les
communautarismes
il ya encore beaucoup à faire sur le
président ainsi en 2018 la fondation
pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé verra le
jour
présidée par jean marc ayrault l'idée
avait été lancée par jacques chirac en
2006 et reprise l'an dernier par
françois hollande
avec cette dernière image d'un président
sur le départ seul au moment de repartir
du sénat quand son successeur se lance
dans un long bain de foule
son premier depuis l'élection
[Musique]
françois hollande prépare l'avenir nos
futurs ex chef de l'état 20 s'investir
dans les prochains mois dans sa
fondation en fera la france s'engage
alors avant de parler de son bilan je
vous propose de l'écouter c'était ce
matin la première fois que je me suis
présenté à une élection j'avais 26 ans
donc je me suis déterminé pour que ce ne
soit pas simplement un moment de mon
existence mais véritablement toute mon
existence je n'avais pas pensé
nécessairement lorsque je me suis
présenté pour la première fois au
suffrage que je deviendrais président de
la république certains peuvent avoir
même une accélération et se présenter
aux suffrages pour la première fois et
devenir président de la république ça
peut arriver
je n'avais pas pensé être président de
la république mais je m'étais engagé
pleinement dans la vie publique
il met invité pour évoquer ce bilan du
quinquennat
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir alain
bergounioux bonsoir vous êtes historien
spécialiste du parti socialiste merci
d'être avec nous j'accueille également
bruno cautrès bonsoir chercheur au cnrs
et membre du cevipof est avec nous
également pour nous accompagner à
jebrane de directeur conseil chez little
rice est une agence conseil en
communication vous êtes co auteur du
livre moi président des couacs aux
éditions kawa merci à tous les trois je
vous ai vu réagir bruno cautrès est ce
que françois hollande vient d'être dit
il nous rappelle un qui n'avait pas
forcément pensé à le président de la
république qu'est ce que ça veut dire
cette phrase justement rétrospectivement
par rapport à tout ce quinquennat très
intéressante parce qu'on retrouve une
rhétorique assez françois hollande c'est
à dire on peut lire à plusieurs niveaux
ce qui est dit on retrouve aussi et bien
une communication qui est à la fois
affectueuse vis-à-vis des manuels macron
et en même temps il ya des éléments qui
sont tout en malice vis-à-vis des
manuels macro il rappelle que lui il a
commencé sa carte politique
à 26 ans donc ça c'est pour dire y'a pas
que toi emmanuel qui a été jeune en
politique
et puis aussi moi je n'ai pas tout de
suite pensé à être président de la
république j'ai franchi les étapes une à
une
donc on retrouve là quelque chose on
voit que françois hollande est depuis
plusieurs semaines
dans un exercice de retisser à la fois
le lien est d'essayer de construire sa
sortie est de construire une narration
autour de sa sortie de la vie politique
en tout cas au minimum de l'elysée est
donc là on voit des éléments qui sont
très intéressants depuis l'élection d'
emmanuel macron et notamment la manière
dont ils essayent de je ne dirais pas de
de prendre emmanuel macron sous son aile
protectrice en tout cas de dire j'y suis
peut-être pas totalement pour rien à
l'élection d' emmanuel macron exercice
délicat de dresser le bilan de ce
quinquennat puisque c'est la première
fois qu'un président finalement sortant
ne se représente pas il a été empêché sa
porte forcément un jugement négatif sur
son action passée le terme d' empêcher a
été utilisé par emmanuel macron pour le
pour le définir
donc donc c'est un je crois que là il
est est en train qu'on nous disait bruno
cautrès de construire un récit et dans
un certain sens
manuel macron ayant été proche de lui
il montre aux français et les images de
la journée du 8 mai était
caractéristique de ce point de vue que
dans le fond son bilan n'est pas si
mauvais puisque anne ses conseillers
hans ministre devient président de la
république donc c'est une manière de
mieux le valoriser le bilan mais en
finesse aussi pour montrer les
différences parce que ensuite il ya les
mois qui vont venir
on verra quelle quel discours il tient
et qu'elle est sûre quel point il veut
insister mais là c'est la construction
effectivement d'un récit qui jusqu'à
présent c'est ça le paradoxe manqué au
quinquennat pour vous le fait qu'il ne
se représente pas par définition ça veut
dire que son bilan est forcément négatif
alors son plan politique ça c'est aux
observateurs politiques de juger mais en
tout cas ce plan de la communication et
d'un symbole c'est vrai que la campagne
électorale n'a pas permis de faire le
bilan de justement de le mandat de
françois hollande ps qui ne s'est pas
représenté on a vu que ce bilan était
complètement absent des discours à la
fois personne ne voulait voir
effectivement le bilan du débat où
marine le pen et c'est justement le fait
reporter macro mm macro justement le
rejeter pour ne pas le porter donc c'est
vrai que le bilan n'a pas été fait
françois hollande et se retrouve
justement l'obligé aujourd'hui une fois
qu'il sort de l'e10 est obligé de le
faire alors qu'il n'a fait ni pendant
son quinquennat
ni justement pendant cette campagne
puisqu'il n'était pas partie prenante à
bord n'ont que très serré qu'il avait la
lourde tâche de faire fructifier cet
héritage socialiste après françois
mitterrand au final est ce qu'il n'est
pas revenue
difficile à dire aujourd'hui parce qu'on
manque encore de recul ce qui est
certain c'est que le mandat de françois
hollande a été caractérisée par une
forme d'impasse au bout d'un moment
c'est à dire que françois hollande s'est
retrouvé président de la république à
l'issue d'une primaire certes mais aussi
à l'issue des primaires ou un autre
candidat qui était
dans l'est aussi en attente n'a pas pu
être candidat à la présidence de
république et françois hollande a
inscrit un mandat qui était amanda qui
en même temps s'inscrivait dans les pas
de françois hollande et en même temps on
était plus dans la même histoire que
france hollande
les communistes ne sont pas au
gouvernement les écologistes de 2012 ne
sont pas exactement l'équivalent de ce
qu'on avait connu au moment de l'union
de la gauche et de et de françois
mitterrand et surtout françois hollande
va subir de plein fouet non seulement
bien sûr les crises qu'on va avoir
autant au plan économique mais surtout
une division extrêmes de la vie sociale
et sur la question de l'europe et à
l'époque de feu à l'époque de fond des
mines d'or
voilà on dont il a été le premiers
secrétaires du parti ou en du référendum
donc on voit qu'elle a quelque chose de
très important qui va marquer avec des
conséquences extrêmement profonde tout
le mandat de françois hollande et qui a
des répercussions jusqu'à ce qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui quasiment y compris dans les
fractures à l'intérieur de la campagne
du candidat voit que vous faisiez la
comparaison avec françois mitterrand je
crois qu'il faut dire très honnêtement
qu'il a hérité en 2012 une situation
beaucoup plus difficile que celle de
françois mitterrand 1981 ou celle de
lionel jospin en 1997 ce qu'il y avait
vraiment une conjonction après la grande
crise financière et économique de 2008
de difficultés et puis difficultés
économiques c'est évident au point de
vue des déficits de la dette de la perte
de compétitivité de la france mais aussi
difficultés politiques parce qu'il faut
rappeler que au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle de 2012 la
gauche rassemblée et qui était en plus
divisée ne faisait que 43 et quelques
pour cent des suffrages donc il était à
la fois économiquement et politiquement
dans une situation difficile et c'est là
qu'il faudrait rentrer commencé à
rentrer dans le fond du débat et c'est
sale et je pense
un des fils sinon rouge tout en point un
des fils de du quinquennat c'est qu'il a
essayé de de sérier les difficultés il
n'a pas voulu et c'est pour ça que la
comparaison avec emmanuel macron est
intéressante parce qu'eux mêmes mâcon
était un de ses conseillers en 2012 et
dans l'équipe pour les deux qu'on trouve
notamment des économistes des manuels
macron on a les mêmes
jean pisani ferry et d'autre et c est là
françois hollande d'emblée a eu un choix
un certain nombre de ses conseillers
dont emmanuel macron lui conseillaient
de faire une série de réformes
structurelles importantes tout de suite
pour réveiller un potentiel de
croissance et lui ne les a pas écoutés
il a voulu diluer les choses avancent et
par étapes d'une première étape après
une 2e et puis dans la troisième on
redistribue ray dont qu'il a il a réagi
en politique et non pas on est ou pas un
économiste
et il est assez intéressant de voir
qu'aujourd'hui emmanuel macron a tiré la
leçon de ses débuts du quinquennat et on
verra évidemment se disent pas ce parce
que les choses ont toujours que
compliqué mais lui il veut faire des
réformes forte tout de suite donc et
françois hollande a réagi en politique
et il a pensé que le calendrier plus
permettrait de résoudre les problèmes
les uns après les autres sans coaliser
les difficultés au rize et on reverra
peut-être on aura l'occasion geste et la
pierre de 2013 2014 il s'est trouvé dans
une impasse politique et c'est les choix
des début de quinquennat ou deux
septennats autrefois sont évidemment
tout à fait majeur justement vous me
faites la transition à la bourgogne oups
croire ce sujet de cendras arkema
puisque françois hollande on l'a dit il
se voulait le chantre du compromis et de
la synthèse au final il n'aura pas
réussi à asseoir son autorité
il laisse un ps en déshérence alors à
l'origine du délitement ses choix
souvent incompris qui ont conduit à la
démission de dont de nombreux ministres
c'est un sujet de sombres affaires car à
6 mai 2012 la gauche en liesse pour
fêter la victoire de françois hollande
ces peuples de france ici rassemblés
d'avoir permis que la gauche ait un
successeur à françois mitterrand
cinq ans plus tard dans l'incapacité à
se représenter
françois hollande laisse un bilan
politique au goût amer
dès les premiers mois de son quinquennat
quoique et recadrages s'enchaînent
jusqu'à ce qu'arnaud montebourg soit
débarqué du gouvernement en 2014
après avoir dénoncé des hausses d'impôts
non prévu dans le programme du candidat
hollande
le monde entier nous presse nous
supplient même de faire cesser ces
politiques d'austérité absurde
même sort pour benoît hamon aurélie
filippetti les cautions de gauche ne
participeront pas au deuxième
gouvernement avec manuel valls ni les
verts la majorité s'effrite puis s'ouvre
une crise morale avec la déchéance de
nationalité voulu par françois hollande
en 2015 après les attentats
christiane taubira figure emblématique
de la gauche quitte le gouvernement sur
un désaccord politique majeure je
choisis d'être fidèle à moi même
fidèle à nous les tensions s'accentuent
avec l'ailé gauche des parlementaires
opposés à la politique sociale libérale
mise en place françois hollande peine à
obtenir une majorité sur de nombreux
projets de loi je connais les
immobilismes et les conservatismes et je
sais aussi que certains préfèrent les
postures à la réforme et les passages en
force avec le 49-3 sur les lois macron
est elle comme riz durcissent encore le
camp des socialistes frondeur et
entérine la fracture au sein du ps nous
pensons qu'il n'est pas possible
d'imposer au groupe socialiste une
unanimité de façade en raison de
l'impasse économique et politique dans
lequel on se trouve
la gauche à son apogée en 2012 enchaîne
les défaites électorales
la synthèse cher à françois hollande
s'achève sur le score pathétique du ps à
la présidentielle
un parti en voie de disparition on
continue le bilan du quinquennat de
françois hollande avec un nouvel ami
taxi nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
pascal boniface bonsoir directeur de
l'iris institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques
auteur de ce livre je t'aimais bien tu
sais aux éditions max milo dans lequel
vous analysez le déclassement de la
france aux yeux du monde
peut-être une question pour vous disiez
jebrane on a vu ces différentes étapes
qui ont marqué le bilan politique du
quinquennat de françois hollande
est ce que il n'y a pas eu aussi
peut-être trop d'ambiguïtés dès 2012 qui
ont conduit à l'exaspération des
français aux difficultés qu'il a pu le
rencontrer françois hollande
effectivement en force hollande n'a
jamais en fait donné la ligne directrice
de son quinquennat le fil rouge qui
voulait donner et inversement quand il a
aidé accès d'autorité
il a voulu justement il est piégé en
devant une grille d'analysé qui l'a
complètement corne arisée vis-à-vis des
journalistes et observateurs notamment
la version la coupe du chômage que
justement il a conditionné sa
candidature et le succès son quinquennat
à cet indicateur est il a forcé en fait
les gens elle jugé par rapport à ça
justement en n'étant pas claires sur ce
qu'ils voulaient faire la une en mai le
pays notamment par rapport à ses
promesses parce que je pense que le
grand la grande difficulté de françois
hollande c'était le grand écart qui a dû
faire entre ses promesses de campagne
campagne très à gauche et une fois qu'il
est au gouvernement des mesures qui
étaient plutôt libérale en tout cas
favorisant la compétitivité donc on sait
de ce grand écart il n'a pas su le gérer
et justement ce qui a créé des amours
d'antan dans l'opinion et s'il ya juste
un mot qu'on peut retenir est que
revient dans la bouche de françois
hollande et vous reprenez vous c'est la
réconciliation
françois hollande a été lui aussi sur la
réconciliation par rapport à un
quinquennat nicolas sarkozy qui était
pas apaisé et on voit que il n'a pas
réussi et micron mise aussi là dessus
pour dire je serai le camp des bleus
président la réconciliation lui a valu
de nombreux procès en trahison tout au
long de 2,5 et nassez changement de cap
à oui mais qui sont sans doute lié à un
problème de à la fois de deux fils
rouges de narration est sans aucun doute
de quelques moments clé sur lequel il a
manqué de donner leur signification à
ces moments clés parce que quand on
reprend le discours du bourget moi je
les réécoute est très nombreuses
reprises vraiment quand on leur écoute
le discours du bourget on s'aperçoit
qu'on ne peut pas dire que françois
hollande ait trahi ses engagements de
campagne de très nombreux points du
discours du bourget qui soit ont été
clairement mis en oeuvre soit ont été
mis à moitié en oeuvre soit il a essayé
de les mettre en oeuvre il a été bloqué
par tout un tas de mécanismes et au fond
ce qu'on a surtout retenu du discours du
bouger c'est de mon ami seulement de la
finance et je renégocie le traité de
stabilité budgétaire
il ya eu un moment où françois hollande
ait said interpréter cette ce double
objectif c'était la crise grecque
c'est vraiment la crise grecque on a à
la fois mon ennemi c'est la finance vous
voyez par rapport aux allemands par
rapport à chaud bleus et puis je vais
renégocier le traité stabilité
budgétaire
je donne une impulsion à l'europe ont
conservé les grecs dans la zone euro
donc là l'europe c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas seulement une question
économique c'est pas seulement une
question de stabilité budgétaire
donc c'est surtout une question de
narration et notamment au moment au
début de l'année 2014
lorsqu'il fait sa fameuse conférence de
presse wild i wish social démocrate
bien sûr et c'est à ce moment là où
françois hollande probablement manque la
balle de match de son quinquennat qui
est de s'engouffrer de dire bah oui
effectivement c'est bien ça et je vais
déployer tout un projet je mettre en
oeuvre toute une histoire et après le 2
le sentiment de constamment navigué
effectivement entre entre différents
courants gauche droite à l'intér de sa
famille politique
allez je crois que ça c'est le point
important parce que c'est le brent de la
méthode politique et comme on peu de
temps je prendrai qu'un seul exemple
pour montrer qu'ils en font il n'a pas
pu expliquer exactement ce qu'il faisait
parce que la question européenne
il avait été engagé à renégocier le
traité le tsc g il s'est rendu compte et
il l'a dit dans le fameux livre avec les
deux journalistes du monde qu'il n'y
avait pas de rapport de force pour
négocier avec l'allemagne que même dans
l'europe du sud espagne italie nous
voulait le suivre c'est un bras de fer
avec l'allemagne
donc alors ce qu'il a fait c'est à dire
qu'il a signé le traité
il a pris des engagements et il a obtenu
une tolérance de la commission
européenne est de l'allemagne pour que
la france diminue ses déficits lentement
et ont d'ailleurs n'est toujours pas
arrivé aux 3% alors que c'était bon et
aimer ça ils ne pouvaient pas
l'expliquer parce qu'il aurait fallu
expliquer justement
le ce deal habile mais qui n'étaient pas
claires et du fait il n'a pas mené une
réelle politique d'austérité
même s'il ya eu des limites dans les
dépenses etc
le pouvoir d'achat a continué à
augmenter dans cette période certes pas
pour tout le monde c'était le problème
du chômage et lancinant et alors il a
été accusé ou trahison par toute la
gauche et même au sein du parti
socialiste de mener une politique
d'austérité d'enfer a été cette
politique d'austérité était extrêmement
modéré mais ça ils ne pouvaient pas
l'expliquer parce que ça tenait un deal
avec essentiellement la chancelière
et puis que je suivais la commission
européenne
donc il a on a mené une politique très
modérée au point de vue aux restrictions
en variété des dépenses publiques très
loin de ce que pouvait raconter la
gauche
la protection sociale a continué à
progresser mais y comment expliquer cela
or c'est c'est tout le problème du de
françois hollande c'est une méthode
politique fait d'habileté pour diluer
les difficultés pour les seriez mais au
total
évidemment et comme il a eus il a eu
vous avez tout le monde avait remarqué
cet ex cette fameuse expression toujours
dans ce livre des quand même très
intéressant pour comprendre le
quinquennat j'ai pas eu de bol donc tout
le monde à dieu qu'est ce que ça veut
dire avoir pas de bol en fait ils
pensaient dilué difficulté et il croyait
que la croissance et une dynamique
cyclique de la croissance et qu'elle
reviendrait simplement elle n'est pas
revenue et donc après il ya eu une
impasse et la fiscalité est apparue
beaucoup trop beaucoup trop forte et on
s'est retrouvé dès 2013 2014
dans une inde dans une très grande
difficulté politique qui n'avaient pas
anticipé comme cela je crois que c'est
comme ça qu'on peut commencer à rendre
compte et de ce qui s'est passé dans ce
quinquennat
pascal boniface de vous entendre ce
qu'on a entendu dans le sujet de sandra
serre car la question de la déchéance de
nationalité a provoqué une véritable
crise morale à gauche sa conduite a été
rappelé à la démission de christiane
taubira sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme là aussi il n'a pas su
expliquer ses choix
alain bergounioux évoquait justement ce
problème d'incompréhension de demandes
de pédagogie n'ont peut-être pas mise à
part sur ce problème très sens
yb des chances de qualité qui a
finalement conduit à une rupture
extrêmement important puisque c'est sur
ce point qu'elle menait le maquereau
s'est séparé de manuel valls est donc de
françois hollande et à l'extérieur aussi
alors qu'il avait réussi une très belle
réconciliation avec l'algérie et qu'il
avait de très bonnes relations avec les
pays du maghreb ça a été vue aussi comme
quelque chose de stigmatisant mais pour
le reste par rapport à la lutte contre
le terrorisme jamais il n'est tombé dans
les provocations dans les raccourcis il
a évité les termes d'islamo fascisme
il était beaucoup plus calme que son
premier ministre là dessus il a refusé
tout amalgame sur musulmans en
terrorisme etc tout en maintenant le cap
et c'est vrai que sur ce domaine là
alors on pourrait dire il y en a
beaucoup parlé et peut-être qu'on a trop
parlé ça ça notre sujet il pouvait
penser qu'il n'était pas possible de
faire autrement par rapport au public
mais en tous les cas il n'a pas mis
d'huile sur le feu sur les peurs des
français
à ce moment là et c'était extrêmement
important parce que dans d'autres pays
où d'autres responsables politiques
avaient une vision un peu plus je dirais
enflammé de la façon de lutter contre le
terrorisme ou même simplement
d'explication des causes du terrorisme
n'est pas lui qui a dit que comprendre
c'est légitimer et c'est donc il ya
quand même maintenu le cap en donnant
les moyens de lutte alors on peut dire
vigipirate etc
on peut le point par point ergoter dans
tous les cas il s'est engagé et à des
moments clés a aussi bien pour le ser le
11 janvier 2015 que après le 13 novembre
il a joué son rôle de chef de l'état en
donnant les moyens de la protection du
territoire des citoyens mais sans tomber
dans les excès de peur et c'est pour
cela que cet épisode des chances de la
qualité est d'autant plus incongrue est
d'autant plus bizarre parce que là du
coup il a voulu faire une sorte de coup
médiatique dont on sait que enfin on
peut débattre mais il est certain que
ceux qui commettent des attentats ne
sont pas effrayés par une éventuelle
perte de nationalité est donc là on a vu
qu'il a plus voulu répondre à une
demande
du milieu politique et médiatique à une
réel besoin de lutte contre le
terrorisme
le 13 avril dernier le disais à
l'hebdomadaire le point je suis
malheureux qu'une partie de la gauche
n'ont pas compris tout ce que nous
faisions
c'est là aussi la clé peut-être pour
comprendre qu'on n'a jamais su ce
qu'était le homeland isme il le dit
lui-même en fait il dit c'est pas moi
définir ce que celle où l'on dise pas ce
que sera la présidence françois hollande
est en fait le problème de françois
hollande c'est que la laisser les autres
parler pour lui mais n'a jamais voulu
justement lui porter un discours et une
vision un fil rouge lova la fin est oui
mais ça c'est que c'est typique de sa
personne et parce que si je fais le
constat sur les questions de relations
internationales
il n'a jamais été en conceptuel il n'a
pas fait comme mitterrand macron s'est
référé dans la campagne au goal au
mitterrandisme hollande a fui ce terme
comme la fuite ou d'autres termes est
donc comme c'est essentiellement un
pragmatique il ya toujours eu peur au
niveau juridique mais je pense que c'est
pareil dans les domaines dont vous êtes
vous ou socialistes d'être enfermé dans
un chat mais à théorique qui l'aurait
rendu prisonnier et sa méthode c'est
toujours de faire effectivement avec
habileté et des arrangements mais s'il
ya une doctrine il est prisonnier et
donc mais en même temps on voit de temps
en temps il faut parler aux gens il faut
expliquer ce que l'on fait dans un cadre
doctrinal et la cp ce1 qui a manqué
effectifs de journalistes sont pas les
commentateurs et du coup qui ont
installé un bruit négatif autour de sa
présidence il n'a pas réussi à le
contrôler y contribuer alors on continue
et d'analyser le bilan du quinquennat de
françois hollande et on sait qu'il avait
conditionné sa candidature à une
inversion de la courbe du chômage le
pari était osé et la poursuit tout au
long du quinquennat
retour sur le bilan économique de
françois hollande avec mounir ceci est
le début du quinquennat françois
hollande se lance dans la bataille pour
l'emploi avec une idée fixe l'objectif
que je me suis fixé c'est d'inverser la
courbe du chômage d'ici la fin de
l'année
plusieurs mesures vont être mises en
place pour stimuler les embauches
les contrats de génération et les
emplois d'avenir pour lutter contre le
chômage des jeunes 325000 moins de 25
ans ont bénéficié de ces contrats de
cinq ans maximum
mais le coeur de la stratégie a reposé
sur un défi lancé au patronat je propose
un pacte de responsabilité aux
entreprises il est fondé sur un principe
simple moins de charges sur le travail
moins de contraintes sur leurs activités
et en même temps
une contrepartie peluche dans bausch et
plus de dialogue social
le pacte de responsabilité couplé au
crédit impôt compétitivité emploi a
dégagé 33 milliards d'euros pour les
entreprises
une somme qui leur a permis de restaurer
leurs marges en berne depuis la crise de
2008 mais n'a pas entraîné la création
d'un million d'emplois comme le
promettait le patron du medef
en cinq ans la courbe s'est stabilisé
mais pas inverser le président avait
fait ses calculs en pariant sur une
croissance retrouvée dynamique dans les
faits elle a navigué entre 0,2 et 1,1
pour cent sur le quinquennat
insuffisant pour doper l'activité la
consommation n'a pas pu jouer son rôle
de moteur traditionnel car les ménages
ont vu leur impôt grimpé de près de 16
milliards en cinq ans sur le plan
budgétaire françois hollande avait
promis de ramener le déficit sous les 3%
dès 2013
finalement ce chiffre sera atteint fin
2017 avec une baisse de plus de 20
milliards
en revanche la dette a continué à se
creuser malgré la faiblesse des taux
d'intérêt elle s'élevait fin 2016 à 98
4% du pib
bruno compterait cette inversion de la
courbe du chômage seul a poursuivi tout
au long de son quinquennat françois
hollande avec ce pacte de compétitivité
qui n'a pas forcément produit les effets
escomptés
on revient à ce qu'on disait totalement
avec cette conversion social libéralisme
en tout cas on a été un peu accusé
justement de naviguer entre deux voies
vous portez un regard à plusieurs
plusieurs dimensions plus d'un niveau 2
dans un premier premier temps on peut
dire que françois hollande ce piège lui
même avec l'inversion de la courbe
d'autant plus qu'il a un deuxième
objectif au début de son mandat qui est
celui de la jeunesse et j'ai toujours
été je me suis toujours interrogé sur
les raisons pour lesquelles il a plus
mis l'accent à un moment donné sur
l'inversion de la coupe plutôt que sur
la question de la sur la question de la
jeunesse et sur la question de la
jeunesse dans un premier temps du
quinquennat on dit on va recruter des
enseignants
mais est ce vraiment répondre aux
demandes et aux besoins de la jeunesse
répond que de recruter des enseignants
et sur l'inversion de la courbe y ait
une deuxième lecture au fond on voit
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron dit eh bien
moi je vais fixer des objectifs et des
critères d'évaluation aux ministres et
ceux qui ne tiendront pas leurs
objectifs seront sanctionnés les députés
dépose candidats
candidate dans marche dépose une lettre
de motivation et quelque part on voit
que françois hollande en même temps est
un détour à roue tout premiers
dirigeants du monde démocratique qui
s'est lui même fixé un critère
d'évaluation et qui en a tiré des
conséquences et donc d'une certaine
manière si on le reprenait sur un très
long sur une très longue durée ce avec
un peu de distance
on va voir françois hollande a aussi en
maintenant montrer aux autres dirigeants
aux autres potentiels dirigeants du pays
car moment donné si on considère qu'on
est un échec sur un de ces dossiers
majeurs on en tire les conséquences et
ça c'est très intéressant puisque l'un
des regard que portent les français sur
leur politique c'est que c'est une
classe d'individus qui ne qui n'est pas
sanctionnés lorsqu'ils sont en échec 106
sans doute faute que les français
pensent à mais en tout cas ils le
pensent beaucoup donc j'ai un regard un
peu partagés sur cette question de
l'inversion de la courbe à l'appui
d'avoir eu notons le pas le fait que
c'est en toute fin de quinquennat
derniers mois quasiment pendant la
campagne et florales qu'un certain
nombre d'indicateurs passe au vert les
simplement comme je le disais tout à
l'heure
françois hollande a pensé que la
dynamique de croissance jour est plutôt
c'était quand même fondé la tuer pour
ceux qui ont de la mémoire qui quand
françois hollande était professeur à
sciences po ou maître de conférences à
sciences po avec pierre moscovici un
cours d'économie dans les années 80 et
ils étaient les partisans de la
croissance endogène donc hollande a
pensé qu'il y avait un cycliste et la
théorie des cycles et qu'il y avait
assez
donc là évidemment lc3 retrouvé en
difficulté ensuite il faut être là vous
en veut employer le mot je crois qu'il
faut parler
là dessus et avoir un débat là-dessus
parce que social libéral oui et non
parce que 1014 considérer les deux comme
c'est manuel va peut-être pas le
meilleur interprète du mon a vis du
quinquennat donc parce que la politique
de l'offre qui lui a été reprochée par
la gauche de la gauche par une partie
par chase tout conte fait françois
mitterrand et lionel jospin s'est déjà
été pratiqué évidemment et à partir de
laurent fabius avait donné comme
consigne aux entreprises publiques de
faire du profit
donc il c'était une politique de l'offre
qui a été menée et lionel jospin avait
justement parce qu'il n'y avait pas il y
avait un manque il a toujours manqué ce
récit explicatif donc il a mené certes
une politique de l'offre et avec des
éléments de politique libérale comme
depuis 1983 il n'y a pas de grande
nouveauté mais en même temps comme je
les dis la protection sociale n'a pas
été mise en cause elle a même progressé
il ya eu des mesures qui ont été prises
qui l'ont fait progresser par rapport à
ce qu'elle était et puis il a tenté très
sincèrement le dialogue social
parce que là on a envie tous sur l'image
de l'année 2016 les manifestations la
loi travail qu'il aurait dû n'est être
plus vigilants sur cette loi travail
devant boris expliquera plus tard
mais au départ 2012 2013 2014 il ya les
grandes conférences social il ya les
accords interprofessionnels et donc en
fait comme le disait très bien pascal
boniface françois hollande c'est un
pragmatique et donc il a additionné des
éléments de politique de la de nature
assez différentes les uns
sociaux-démocrates les autres sociaux
libéraux et avec une volonté
effectivement de dialogue social et
d'apaisement
simplement il les résultats n'ont pas
été là parce que et c'est là qu'on
pourrait avoir un débat plus
contradictoire parce que certains disent
parce qu'il a eu tort il fallait
pratiquer une politique de la demande
c'est
et frondeur etc et puis d'autres disent
c'était un peu la thèse d' emmanuel
macron et c'est sa thèse c'est parce
qu'il n'est pas allé assez loin dans les
réformes structurelles et qu'il est
resté à mi-chemin au lieu d'aller
vraiment au fond et c'est vrai que
paradoxalement faire une loi travail
telle qu'elle a été en fin de
quinquennat
c'était quand même pas dire là d'une
habileté extraordinaires parce que c'est
des choses qu'il fallait faire bien
avant quand le gouvernement il y avait
une certaine encore popularité encore
qu'elle a baissé assez vite mais voilà
donc et je crois que le pragmatisme a
ses mérites mais il a aussi ses
faiblesses qui n'aurait pas dû peut-être
qu'on parlait des ambiguïtés et des dés
le début du quinquennat
élargir aussi à son gouvernement dès
2012 peut-être au centre en faisant
entrer des personnels comme françois
bayrou pour mieux faire accepter cette
politique de l'offre qu'il avait mise en
place par la suite si complètement après
ce qui est paradoxal dans françois
hollande ont beau connaisseur de la vie
politique c'est qu'il a placé son
quinquennat sous le signe chômage de la
campagne j'aime puis après dès les
premiers jours du mandat
donc c'est vrai qu'il aurait pu faire un
acte politique fort pour expliquer cette
démarche là mais moi je me pose la
question pourquoi il a voulu être sur ce
terrain glissant de l'économie dont on
se rappelle de milieux de villepin quand
il était premier ce qui avait placé
aussi son quinquennat sa bataille contre
le chômage
donc c'est un terrain glissant pour
beaucoup de politiques depuis un moment
pareil c'est pas forcément le terrain où
la gauche la plus légitime tout cas plus
crédible il aurait pu effectivement
accès son quinquennat sur la protection
sociale sur le mariage pour tous des
vraies réformes sociétales qui l'a mené
donc le chef françois hollande est assez
assez y pose question en tout cas et on
le voit bien dans les mots qu'ils
utilisent
il passe d'abord de boîte à outils qui
est un mot justement qui ne veut pas
dire grand chose et qui ramène la
présidence quelque chose d'assez
opérationnel il passe ensuite impact on
parle ensuite de jugement ou l'inversion
de la courbe du chômage on sait il n'a
jamais vraiment trouvé le bon ton en
tout cas le bon vocabulaire pour
expliquer ça que sa politique aux
français tu es bien un écart aussi entre
les réformes sur le plan sociétal qui
auront ils réussi qui était populaire et
l'absence d'un état économique dont
beaucoup de gens se sont dit on s'occupe
toujours un et maryse y un des
privilégiés d'une certaine catégorie
sociaux social ceux du rationnel et donc
ce décalage entre
réformes qui ont été dix ont largement
approuvé au moins dans dans certains
milieux mais qui donc n'ont pas profité
beaucoup de gens et l'absence de
résultats concrets notamment sur le
chômage
c'était évident et pour revenir ce que
dit c'est sûr que le discours du bourget
pourrait peut-être être plus global mais
ce qu'ont retenu les jaunes et ce qui a
justifié le vote j-1 du coup en 2012 il
bat largement mélenchon parce que il
incarne le vote de gauche il s - espace
à mélenchon et cécile mélenchon a eu
plus d'espacés en 2017 c'est aussi
d'être en mémoire de 2012 et 2 1 des
vécus comme des engagements non
respectés par rapport aux questions
sociales
on a un peu abandonnés ils ont que
hollande a privilégié le sociétal sur le
social emmanuel vaste l'identitaire sur
le social mais le social a quand même
été même s'il n'a pas été bafouée par
rapport aux promesses par amour aux
espoirs de 2012 il a quand même été un
peu l'oublié du quinquennat il n'y a pas
eu de la grande réforme symbolique
il ya eu enfin les grandes réformes qui
étaient plus le des symboles sous
mitterrand parce qu'il ya eu une
politique de l'offre mais des réformes
importantes et celui en est justement
les 35 heures et dominique strauss kahn
à l'économie avec une politique très en
réalité très social libéral et des
privatisations
mais là il a manqué aux dés il ya eu des
petites réformes sociales mais par rien
qui n'a acquis n'a marqué l'opinion
qu'ils soient suffisamment les îles si
j'avais en lisible pour équilibrer le
par exemple mariage pour tous qui la
grande réforme sociétale mais qui
effectivement ne quand ses intérêts
c'est qu'une partie de la france et pas
l'autre
je pense moins à peu près ce jeu je
pense que tous les problèmes dont dont
on parle si on essaie de mettre côté la
responsabilité politique de deux de
françois hollande c'est tout simplement
que une autre personnalité aurait
affronté sans aucun doute les mêmes
difficultés et emmanuel macron va les
affronter la politique dans les pays de
l'europe
globalement c'est une politique en deux
dimensions il ya la dimension socio
économique qui continue d'animer une
très grande partie du débat public des
clivages sur lequel vient se greffer la
question de la gauche et la droite
et puis la deuxième dimension plus du
changement culturel du changement social
et
toutes toutes formes pas le taux de
formation politique doit essayer de
naviguer un peu entre les exigences
contradictoires de ces deux dimensions
si on va trop sur l'économique
eh bien on va peut-être s'aliéner une
partie de l'opinion qui elle aspire à du
changement culturel et sociétal et
réciproquement et rappelons nous qu'au
début de son mandat
françois hollande beaucoup de gens à
gauche et notamment à l'inter du parti
socialiste disait avec les réformes de
société qu'il a initiés il oublie
l'objectif numéro 1 la lutte contre le
chômage les classes populaires et le
parti socialiste depuis maintenant 20
ans est dans une sorte de quête des
classes populaires qu'il a perdu en
partie ou même en assez large partie on
l'a vu encore dans les élections de 2017
et la gauche n'arrive pas à faire sans
donner des classes populaires parce que
sinon évidemment
qu'est ce que c'est que la gauche si
elle abandonne message d'espoir pour les
classes populaires et donc cette
question elle est posée pas seulement au
parti socialiste elle se faisant tous
les partis sociaux démocrates ces fonds
ce land il a essayé de jongler à travers
tout ça mot pour ça rattrape rennes
annuels maximaux pour souligner ce que
vous dites parce que il faut essayer
d'être équilibrés c'est à dire que en
fait quand on regarde l'europe
tous les gouvernements de type
travailliste sociaux démocrates
socialistes ont connu des difficultés
qu'ils soient en angleterre la fin de la
troisième voie en espagne c'est évident
une rigueur et n'zi qui est un peu le
maquereau italiens aussi donc
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut quand même
il ya on va y aller les critiques sont
utile et nécessaire et puis comme ça se
termine mal c'est pour évidemment on
voit bien qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui n'ont pas marché on a commencé en
expliquer quelques rudes mais la
situation était extrêmement difficile et
aucun les grands leaders socialistes
européens n'a réussit dans son pays tout
juste est encore sur un équilibre
fragile le gouvernement des sociaux
démocrates suédois mais c'est même en
suède même ensuite c'est difficile donc
donc il faut voir
on est dans un ensemble etc les
difficultés d'un de la social démocratie
européenne à faire face aux
contradictions
cette collection d'instants injonction
contradictoire parce qu'il faut faire
plusieurs choses
ils ne vont pas ensemble qu'on verra sur
cette question de l'europe oui on qu'on
parle de celui qui voulait quand même
incarner un président normal proche du
peuple et qui atteint des sommets
d'impopularité un réputé pudique avare
en confidences il s'est finalement
épanché auprès des journalistes cécile 6
au premier pas à les viser et première
maladresse françois hollande serre la
main de nicolas sarkozy mais ne le
raccompagne pas jusqu'à sa voiture
inexpérience ou impolitesse dès le
départ le nouveau chef de l'état ne
maîtrise pas les codes et de l'image
d'un président qui a du mal à enfiler
les habits de la fonction même jour son
costume prend déjà l'eau il remonte les
champs elysées sous une pluie battante
une mauvaise météo qui ne quittera pas
avec une image emblématique sur l'île de
saint lô françois hollande refuse le
parapluie et prononce un discours sous
un véritable déluge un président trempé
désacraliser anormal mauvaise
communication aussi lors de la sphère
leonarda une collégienne rome de 15 ans
dont l'arrestation et l'expulsion avait
suscité l'émoi des français françois
hollande veut lui même éteindre
l'incendié
il propose dans une allocution téléphone
fille de rentrer en france mais sans sa
famille non lui répond l'adolescent par
médias interposés séquence
catastrophique pour le chef de l'état
ridiculisés mais ce qui écorne
particulièrement son image ce sont les
feuilletons liées à sa vie privée
le tweet d'abord de valérie trierweiler
qui encourage l'adverse
r de ségolène royal aux législatives la
photo ensuite dans un magazine people où
la france est la compagne de françois
hollande découvre la liaison du
président avec julie gayet le livre
enfin merci pour ce moment de son ex
compagne valérie trierweiler qui étalent
au grand jour leur rupture et dévoile le
surnom que donne le président aux gens
modestes les fameux 100 dans il y a
quelques mois la publication d'un livre
confidences
un président ne devrais pas dire ça dont
les révélations consterne dans son
propre camp dégrade encore un peu plus
sa stature de chef d'état et donne
l'impression que françois hollande passe
plus de temps avec les journalistes qu'à
s'occuper des affaires de l'état hébreu
vous qui êtes expert en communication
politique à un mot quand même sur son
cinq années et sur la gestion de son
image elle a été calamiteuse je pense
qu'elle a été calamiteuse a été
effectivement un des facteurs de ça nous
représente enfin non candidature à
l'élection présidentielle
il a jamais en fait su trouver ni le bon
ton ni la bonne hauteur justement le
titre du livre justement est assez
révélateur à présent tu ne devrais pas
dire ça parce que françois n'a jamais su
ce qu'un président devaient dire ou
devait faire il a jamais vraiment
compris en deux centres quel costume du
président et on voit bien même sur des
choses très symbolique sur le fait que
soit l'âge de 5 ans il prononce son
discours où il dit c'est bien montrer
comme les résistants en leur temps que
j'affronte les éléments il comprend pas
en fait de l'effet désastreux que ça sur
le pignon il sur son image en fait ils
arrivent pas justement percevoir la
perception que les français on a enfin
la l'image les effets 2 sur son image
que les français pas avoir de lui et
c'est assez désastreux et puis il n'a
pas non plus compris le changement avec
les médias d'information en continu avec
les réseaux sociaux on le voit que
valérie trierweiler avec la faire le
jardin
il n'a pas compris en fait par rapport à
l'époque où il était premier secrétaire
du parti ali souhaité communiquer
directement avec journalistes par sms il
n'a pas compris le monde avait
radicalement changé et que justement la
communication avait complètement changé
d'époque et de mode de fonctionnement
mais peut-être là une petite nuance
quand même parce que c'est vrai mais en
même temps c'est le même homme qui a
pris des décisions en cours importante
en politique internationale et du monde
reconnaît seront censés l'impôt qu'au
moment des attentats que ce soit en
janvier
et en novembre depuis qu'il a été à la
hauteur et avec le souci
comme le disait pascal boniface de
rassembler de tenir le pays et dans un
an dans une réalité démocratique et donc
voilà donc c'est un peu la dualité 1005
en temps normal mais il a été et c'est
normal c'est exactement et les français
vont françois hollande est quelqu'un qui
est personnellement sympathique il n'est
pas arrogant il n'est pas qu'à sang etc
mais les français veulent un peu de
régalien et donc c'est vrai que le livre
passer son temps avec des gens disent
pour raconter les secrets d'état ont pu
cela du coup il y a dans le quotidien un
manque de distance et de fonctions du
costume de président qui doit certes
être près du peuple qui ne voient peut
plus être en dehors et qui ne peut plus
être un monarque comme auparavant même
si françois hollande comme d'autres us à
courre enfin bon ça c'est des phénomènes
auxquels je pense qu'on va être
confronté houle et déjà on sentait
d'ailleurs ses rebonds mais il peut être
que on attendait un peu autre chose
on en attend un peu une chose d'un
président que du camarade sympathique
qui est toujours disponible
la présidence il a voulu marquer une
rupture et lyon ce ça explique en partie
cela explique en partie c'est-à-dire la
volonté de france hollande d'apparaître
comme l'antithèse de nicolas sarkozy est
très frappante au début de son mandat
on a le sentiment même que dans ses
décisions il faut systématiquement
prendre le contre-pied de nicolas
sarkozy mais au fond tout les deux
françois hollande et nicolas sarkozy on
verra pour emmanuel macron ils sont les
contemporains d'une transformation du
rôle et de la communication du rôle
exécutif et on voit que tout le monde
cherche un point d'équilibré une bonne
mesure entre l'ancien style
effectivement très dans le magistère
dans le monarchique et puis en même
temps ne pas tomber dans le président de
république est une sorte de deux gros
premier ministre de super premier
ministre on voit qu'ils ont du mal tous
les deux les deux précédents précise
président a trouvé le rôle parce que
nicolas sarkozy aussi avec beaucoup de
difficultés avec l'incarnation du rôle
présidentiel et pour emmanuel macron on
peut se poser des questions on commence
à apercevoir dans sa communication aussi
peut-être aussi des éléments
d'incertitude sur ce rôle quand on le
voit est bien traversé la cour du louvre
l'esplanade du louvre là aussi on voit
qu une volonté de fer dans le magistère
dans le solennel et en même temps on
sent bien que quelque part c'est c'est
ambigu c'est une communication qui
apparaît presque surdimensionné pour
l'événement 2 2 dimanche soir dont ils
sont tout simplement des contemporains
d'une transformation très important du
rapport des citoyens au pouvoir qui
n'est plus à des années lumière
effectivement les réseaux sociaux etc
ils se cherchent tous je suis en partie
d'accord est un lycée qui a pris
contre-pied france hollande a pris le
contre-pied nicolas sarkozy notamment
avec la présence en mal qui est aussi un
concept en opposition à dominique
strauss kahn à la base mais l'aja mais
en fait défini ce qu'était la présidence
normale la wii il aurait pu
effectivement partir de ce concept là
qui était un concept fort de campagne
qui avait contribué en sans doute en
partie à sa victoire sans définir et en
fait il l'a réduit à des artifices comme
prendre le train plutôt que l'avion
prendre la voiture pour les accule
plutôt que l'avion où passait ses
vacances ses premières vacances on voit
ses photos dans la presse people de lui
en maillot de bain avec sa compagne pour
celle qui n'a jamais vraiment défini on
vient ce fil rouge admiration et
emmanuel macron a tenté de le faire mais
on verra si pourri ne sera pas
prisonnier lui aussi de ses concepts de
campagne en disant je serai un président
qui préside je laisserais mon premier ce
premier disque ou vernet elle revient en
fait à l'esprit la vème république avec
un petit peu de hauteur et on voit bien
que
l'événement du louvre était aussi pour
montrer justement la hauteur de la
présence de répliques en tout cas ce
qu'elle devrait avoir comme auteur alors
en difficulté sur le plan national
françois hollande a en revanche redorer
son blason sur la scène internationale
s'il a su restaurer la crédibilité de la
france et de son armée n'a peut-être pas
su définir de véritables cap notamment
résoudre la crise en syrie flora sauvage
la signature de l'accord de paris à
l'issue de la coop 21 est un succès du
quinquennat de françois hollande
il réalise l'impensable mettre d'accord
195 délégations étrangères
le 12 décembre 2015 le premier texte
universel contraignant sur le climat est
signé même s'il donald trump a menacé de
se retirer de l'accord de paris la coop
21 restera une réussite personnelle pour
le chef de l'état français car il
s'agissait d'un pari risqué
autre fait marquant du quinquennat les
opérations extérieures assure à françois
hollande
une réputation de chef de guerre janvier
2013 des colonnes de djihadistes menace
bamako ils lancent l'opération serval au
mali qui mettra fin à cette offensive et
c'est en héros qu'il est accueilli à
bamako la capitale malienne
un mois plus tard
aucun village ne doit occuper par deux
théories échapper
en centrafrique françois hollande lance
l'opération sans garris en décembre 2013
pour mettre un terme aux violences
intercommunautaires
concernant l'europe son bilan est plus
mitigé sur le dossier grec
il a su s'imposer entre le rigorisme de
berlin et la politique anti austérité
d'athènes mais le couple franco allemand
n'a pas toujours été au beau fixe sur la
gestion de la crise migratoire
enfin le grand échec de la politique
étrangère du quinquennat restera la
syrie françois hollande n'a pas réussi à
imposer la voix de la france dans la
résolution de ce conflit
je continue néanmoins de regretter je le
dis devant vous que la communauté
internationale n'ait pas agi en temps
voulu pour faire cesser les massacres en
syrie après l'échec de l'intervention
internationale avortée avec le
renoncement de washington paris a peu à
peu été écartée du dossier syrien
aujourd'hui la france pèse peu au
moyen-orient pascal boniface françois
hollande chef de guerre c'est là
peut-être qu'il s'est le plus révélé ça
ce qu'on vous dit rien oui effectivement
alain valium le mentionnait tout à
l'heure il a su prendre décision rapide
pour attendrir au mali qui a été
efficace les américains eux mêmes été
bluffé en disant nous on n'aurait pas pu
agir dans des circonstances aussi rapide
et donc l'opération au mali c'est
l'exemple même d'opération militaire
réussie alors que la plupart des autres
opérations militaires occidentales en
afrique ou ailleurs ont échoué parce
qu'il y avait un consensus international
qui avait une demande du pays qu' il y
avait surtout le jour d'après il y avait
un objectif politique sert c'est
l'exemple inverse de la libye on a dit
on veut de la communication et on ne
pense pas après pour le bilan
international il ya quand même des
réussites la coop 21 dont on a parlé
intervention mali il ne faut pas oublier
les accords de minsk parce qu'il n'a pas
tout à fait rompu avec la russie alors
qu'on lui demandait de dire non il faut
même pas recevoir
poutine aux commémorations du 100e
anniversaire du débarquement
mais c'est peut-être la plus que jamais
qu'il a manqué un récit que dans pour
les pays extérieurs on se demande un peu
où est la france et pragmatiquement du
coup par coup
c'est bien mais il n'a pas su incarner
la fait enfin lorsqu'on apprend que la
nsa espionne
ils y vont c'est balle et on continue
quand même il n'a pas su de temps en
temps parce qu'il n'est pas clivant
faire les gestes que aussi bien de
gaulle mitterrand et chirac ont fait
leur temps de taper du poing sur la
table et de dire aussi bien aux
américains qu'aux autres et bien il faut
faire cela et puis manquants mais aussi
là une grosse trahison des engagements
la non reconnaissance de la palestine
c'est un engagement fort du début de son
quinquennat qu'il n'a pas fait largement
pour les raisons de politique intérieure
mais qui du coup un peu terni le
prestige de la france dans cette région
parce que la france était depuis de
gaulle depuis mitterrand l'avocat de
cette cause donc c'est un bilan qui est
très contrastée mais qui surtout fait
que comme il n'a pas illustré d'un récit
même il n'a pas su finalement de temps
en temps prendre le taureau par les
cornes et dire aux américains non ce
n'est pas possible ou ou d'autres comme
l'ont fait en leur temps
ses prédécesseurs et bien la visibilité
de la france n'est pas terminé il ya
toujours une attente mais elle s'est
légèrement estompées
malgré quelques succès remarquable non
ramadier nous a également rejoint sur ce
plateau bonsoir noureuil spécialiste des
questions européennes poursuivent et que
senna on a parlé du bilan de françois
hollande sur le plan international à eau
quel bilan vous dressez vous sur le plan
européen justement autant dire dalfin
que c'est un bilan en 2000 en
demi-teinte pardon en 2012 on se
souvient lui président il avait promis
de réformer l'europe remettent de la
croissance et de l'emploi
dans cette europe osterrieth r autant
dire que sur ce premier chantier il n'a
pas du tout aboutit on se souvient du
traité budgétaires européens négocient
en pleine crise de l'euro par nicolas
sarkozy qui posait le principe d'un
retour à l'équilibré des finances
publiques qui a été adopté à la virgule
près par le parlement français est donc
à l'image de ce péché originel du tsc
j'ai comme on l'appelle au le françois
hollande et les questions européennes le
bilan est plutôt maigre il a échoué à
réorienter l'europe que je vous disais
sur la croissance il a échoué dans
l'approfondissement de la zone euro il a
échoué dans son projet de proposer des
'eurobonds' les obligations des
euro-obligations afin de mutualiser les
dettes souveraines européennes il a
échoué à renouer le lien entre les
français et l'union européenne 1 sur 2 1
pour rappel à voter pour des partis
eurosceptiques voir europhobe au premier
tour de cette présidentielle
un lien qu'il a toujours eu lui même du
mal à définir sachant qu' il était
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
en 2005 alors que le référendum sur la
constitution européenne a déchiré son
parti sa gestion tiède aussi de la crise
des réfugiés étaient particulièrement
critiquée notamment
double discours vis-à-vis de berlin et
d'angela merkel qui a pris en charge
seul la gestion de la crise et qui a
pris en charge seul l'accord qui a été
négocié avec la turquie avec l'aide de
la commission européenne qui a permis de
tarir un petit peu ce flux également son
incapacité à tenir ses engagements
budgétaires le dogme et des 3% certains
l'appellent le dogme et les 3% qui n'a
rien arrangé
françois hollande là-dessus or a braqué
les allemands aura trahi ce contrat de
confiance dans ce couple formé par
berlin et paris une confiance qui a été
difficilement possible à renouer le seul
moment où il a été incapable en fait de
recréer ce lien
c'est après les attentats de charlie
hebdo et de l'hyper cacher donc le 11
janvier 2005 avec cette photo dont on se
souvient tous 1,7 et paul posée par
angela merkel sur donc françois hollande
à l'aune de cette manifestation
rapidement lui reconnaît aussi quelques
victoires
effectivement la victoire on en parlait
tout à l'heure le dossier ukrainien et
le dossier grec le dossier ukrainien il
a permis par ses talents de négociateur
grâce aussi à un gala merkel de créer ce
lien et d'éviter l'escaladé en fait dans
le dossier ukrainien après l'annexion de
la crimée et sur la grèce il a évité
clairement ingres excite en allant aider
en fait alexis tsipras ce qu'elle ait
beaucoup de difficulté à discuter avec
leurs groupes et notamment avec
l'orthodoxe wolfgang schauble le
ministre des finances allemand celui en
somme qui en parle le mieux finalement
c'est pierre moscovici son ancien
ministre de l'économie et actuelle
commissaire européen aux finances il le
qualifie avec une pointe de déception
hollande n'a pas été moteur en europe en
gros il reste plutôt l'image d'un
gestionnaire à défaut d'un visionnaire
d'achille points alain bergounioux vous
avez eu la grâce
quelques nuances parce qu'elle bon on
parlait tout à l'heure d'un symbole fort
il restera dans l'histoire le symbole de
janvier 2015
mais on voyait des images voilà alors
évidemment un symbole un peu imposée
mais est quand même extrêmement fort
ensuite c'est tout le débat sur la
question européenne
parce que ici c'est vrai en europe comme
nationalement si lille a adopté une
démarche pragmatique parce que il n'a
pas tenu ses engagements des trois pour
cent parce qu'il ne voulait pas les
tenir et il a obtenu je le redis je vais
dire début d'émission et il a obtenu
l'allemagne une tolérance pour ça mais
en même temps il fallait signer le
traité et en même temps on ne peut pas
dire qu'il ne s'est rien passé en europe
dans ces cinq ans parce que je me
souviens des débats qu'il pouvait y
avoir dans les années 2000 il fallait
que la banque centrale européenne
cessent de de s'occuper uniquement de
l'inflation et la banque centrale
européenne a joué un rôle majeur pour
pour éviter la crise et à une politique
quand on aurait rêvé il ya dix ans de ce
point de vue il ya eu l'union bank est
accepté il ya des choses qui se sont
passées en europe mais et françois
hollande a estimé à tort ou à raison
le débat continuera puis il y aura des
pièces d'archivés témoignages que il la
france n'avait pas le rapport de force
pour faire bouger l'europe seul et c'est
vrai qu'il avait quand même pas eu et
qui n'avait pas beaucoup d'alliés et le
socialisme européens étaient divisés sur
ces questions là pascal boniface manque
d'harmonie
bien des socialistes européens à mener
une action efficace convenable en europe
oui puis moi il y manquait d'allier
effectivement les italiens 2 sur lequel
il s'appuie autant dépareront eu une
crise gouvernementale
je voulais revenir d'un mot sur la syrie
qui a été évoqué dans ce reportage
parce que l'accusation de dire c'est la
france qui n'a pas non la france n'a pas
réussi à résoudre la crise syrienne
pas plus que la russie pas plus que les
états unis pas plus que l'iran pas plus
qu'aucun autre pays et est donc il est
injuste de critiquer uniquement la
france et françois hollande par contre
moi je n'achète pas le discours qui est
le discours reconstruit de françois
hollande et du gouvernement ne dira si
on faisait écouter en septembre 2013 ont
été bombardés plus aurait été réglé non
on aurait été dans une situation
catastrophique parce que quand on est
membre permanent du conseil de sécurité
dans sa pelle la france on se lance pas
dans une guerre sans feu vert du conseil
de suivi n'est donc heureusement qu'on
l'a pas fait et là on voit bien qu'il ya
une tentation de faire du storytelling
sur le fait
si on vous écoute et à l'époque la crise
syrienne aurait été réglé c'est faux
donc il est injuste de l'attaqué de pas
l'avoir réglée il serait injuste de dire
que si on a écouté la france à l'été
2013 la paix serait arrivé en cl on a
évoqué quand même s'il a comme 21 soit
c'était un succès impôts peut-être
masquer les erreurs de communication du
président là il a quand même capitaliser
sur son image à cette occasion oui
laissons quand même la place à laurent
fabius qui était lui le maître d'oeuvre
de la cap 21
mais c'est que la tenue de ce sommet
international très important pour
réchauffement climatique par contre le
réchauffement climatique
quelques semaines après l'attentât quand
même 2 novembre 2015 était un grand défi
pour la france
les françois hollande a quand même
réussi à d'autres événements à deux
occasions aussi comme les la
commémoration du débarquement à réunir
tous ces chefs d'état et de gouvernement
dans une pièce pour une belle photo de
famille mais ça reste quand même des
images des symboles et c'est pas une
action de fond que la russie a menés là
c'est même plus qu'un symbole la
convention y croit quand même plus assez
rentable de causer la vérité c'est bien
sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]